This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
这是一个I-Heart播客。真人保证。2%。当有自动扶梯可用时，只有这个比例的人会选择走楼梯。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，如何展现心理韧性、保持健康以及建立恢复力。让自己经历一些艰难险阻，你最终就会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends.
欢迎收听《2%》。即数字 TWO，可在 IHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。当一群女性发现她们约会过的竟然是同一个惯犯骗子时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们常说，相信你的闺女朋友。听听闺女朋友们的话。
Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
相信我，宝贝。可在 IHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games.
与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家们一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。那真是个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。在 IHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Look Back At It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯。
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that they're not. you need to listen to learn the hard way on the iha radio app apple podcast or wherever you get your podcast hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology hello everybody welcome back to the show welcome back to the podcast new listeners old listeners
这个空间聚焦于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都根本不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一位懂行的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。这并不意味着不需要。你需要在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。大家好，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一个探讨我们二十多岁时的一些重大生活改变和转折点及其对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好，欢迎回到节目，欢迎回到播客，新听众老听众们，
wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, I'm introducing a new kind of episode to the show, a shorter episode than what you are probably used to, where we are going to cover some core psychology principles, theories, concepts, or studies that I think are interesting, that I think will help us understand our 20s better, but which don't necessarily have enough to say about them to be made into a full 45 minute to an hour long episode. And you guys know I love to yap. I can talk I can talk until the sun goes down. But these episodes are just going to be a little bit more bite sized, a little bit smaller for your 15 minute commute, for your 15 minute, I don't know,
无论你身在世界何处，很高兴你能来到这里收听又一期节目，当然，我们要剖析二十岁的心理学。今天，我将向节目中引入一种新类型的节目，比你通常习惯的节目要短，我们将在这里涵盖一些核心的心理学原则、理论、概念或研究，我认为这些很有趣，我认为它们将帮助我们更好地理解我们的二十岁，但它们本身并没有足够的讨论内容来做成一个长达45分钟到一小时的完整节目。你们知道我喜欢闲聊。我能一直说个不停，直到太阳下山。但这些节目会更加精简一点，更小巧一些，适合你15分钟的通勤，适合你15分钟的，我不知道，
arm workout for whatever you're doing, this is just going to be like a more bite-sized taste of our longer episodes talking about concepts that I still think deserve to be in the psychology of your 20s universe, but which just don't have enough research to them quite yet. For our inaugural Psychology Bites bonus episode, I wanted to talk about one of my favorite theories that I've been trying to make into a full-length episode for years. finally she is having her time to shine. We are talking about the triangular theory of love. Let's start with some very basic factual information. This theory was developed by the psychologist Robert Sternberg, and it's not just about romantic love. This theory is about how love forms,
手臂训练或者无论你在做什么，这只是一小部分精简版的长篇节目，谈论那些我仍然认为应该属于“二十岁心理学”宇宙的概念，但它们的研究还不够充分。对于我们的第一期“心理学小点心”红利剧集，我想聊聊我最喜欢的理论之一，我多年来一直想把它做成一期完整的节目。终于，它迎来了发光发热的时刻。我们要聊的是爱情的三角理论。让我们从一些非常基础的事实信息开始。这个理论是由心理学家罗伯特·斯滕伯格提出的，它不仅关乎浪漫的爱情。这个理论关乎爱情是如何形成的，
how it lasts, how it changes, and it's about platonic intimacy, it's about familial intimacy, it's about commitment and the foundational reasons why we feel drawn or connected to certain people and what makes a relationship consummate love, what makes a relationship a kind of love that lasts. It is one theory in a long line of theories trying to synthesize, explain, simplify, categorize the thing that fascinates us more than anything else. it's just one of many theories trying to get to the bottom of what does love really mean? What is this thing that we all experience or hope to experience? Some other theories of note which you are maybe familiar with include things like attachment theory.
它如何持久，如何改变，它关乎柏拉图式的亲密关系，关乎家庭亲密关系，关乎承诺以及我们为什么会被某些人吸引或感到与他们产生连接的根本原因，是什么让一段关系成为完美之爱，是什么让一段关系成为能够持久的爱。这是长久以来试图综合、解释、简化、分类那些比任何其他事物都更令我们着迷的事物的众多理论中的一个。这只是众多试图探究爱情真正含义的理论之一；这是我们所有人都在经历或渴望经历的这种东西吗？其他一些你可能熟悉的值得注意的理论包括依恋理论等。
Basically that theory states that how we love and are loved is based on the love we received as children and how we were raised. There's also the reward theory of attraction, which basically states that, that we are drawn to people who make us feel good about ourselves and that reward inherent drivers within us or inherent desires or needs within us. Another particularly famous theory around love is John Allen Lee's color wheel theory of love, which defines three primary, three secondary,
基本上，该理论指出，我们如何爱以及如何被爱，是基于我们作为儿童时所受到的爱以及我们的抚养方式。还有吸引力的奖赏理论，该理论基本上指出，我们会被那些让我们对自己感觉良好的人所吸引，这种奖赏顺应了我们内在的驱动力、内在的欲望或需求。另一个关于爱情的著名理论是约翰·艾伦·李的爱情色彩轮理论，它定义了三种主要的、三种次要的
and nine tertiary types of love based on different combinations of feelings. For example, Lodos love, which is primarily driven, by desire to have fun and to tease, pragma love, which is a convenient kind of love, kinship love, friendship love, there's a whole list that you can look up. We're not talking about that today. It's just another one of many theories in this kind of space, but the real one that kind
以及基于不同情感组合的九种第三类爱情。例如，勒多斯之爱，主要受寻求乐趣和戏谑的欲望驱使；普拉玛之爱，是一种实用型的爱；亲情之爱，友情之爱，你可以查阅的列表还有很多。我们今天不谈这个。这只是这个领域众多理论中的又一个，但真正脱颖而出并被许多人讨论的
of shines through and that a lot of people talk about is the triangular theory. This is probably my favorite of all, which is, of course, why we are doing an episode on it. So this theory is almost 40 years old now. I think it's over 40 years old, sorry to say. And it suggests that we can describe nearly all types and forms of love based on three ingredients and their combination. The three ingredients for any type of relationship are intimacy, passion, and commitment. Let's break these down.
是三角理论。这可能是我最喜欢的一个，当然这也是为什么我们要专门做一期关于它的节目。所以这个理论现在已经快40岁了。我想它已经超过40岁了，不好意思要这么说。它表明，我们可以根据三个要素及其组合来描述几乎所有类型和形式的爱情。任何类型关系的三个要素是亲密、激情和承诺。让我们把这些拆解开来。
Intimacy involves feelings of familiarity, closeness, connectedness, a sense of similarity, shared hobbies, shared values, that kind of thing. Passion involves deep desire, attraction, romance, feelings of being swept off our feet, and commitment. Commitment means staying. It means trust. It represents shared goals and unity even in hard times. I like to explain this theory as a theory that likes us to think of love like a recipe for a cake. Depending on how much of each of these ingredients you put into the cake, you're going to get a different flavor.
亲密包含熟悉感、亲近感、连结感、相似感、共同的爱好、共同的价值观等感受。激情包含深深的欲望、吸引力、浪漫、神魂颠倒的感觉，以及承诺。承诺意味着留下。它意味着信任。它代表着共同的目标，即使在艰难时期也能保持团结。我喜欢把这个理论解释为一个把爱情想象成蛋糕食谱的理论。根据你放入蛋糕中的每种成分的多少，你会得到不同的风味。
A different flavor of cake that represents something different. It's still a cake. You're just influencing the recipe so that something different comes out. Basically, this theory, it describes love as a recipe, and you can make dozens of different things with just a few variations of ingredients. This is my own kind of metaphor for this theory, but the way Sternberg represents this is as a triangle. Obviously, it's called the triangular theory of love.
代表不同事物的不同蛋糕风味。它仍然是一个蛋糕。你只是在调整食谱，从而产出不同的东西。基本上，这个理论将爱情描述为一个食谱，只需稍微改变几种成分，你就可以做出几十种不同的东西。这是我对这个理论的一种比喻，但斯滕伯格将其呈现为一个三角形。显而易见，它被称为爱情的三角形理论。
And intimacy, passion, and commitment are all points on the triangle. Each point represents one type of love, but so do the lines connecting those points and the center point of the triangle as well. I know it's quite visual, but I think giving you some combinations might help you understand this a little bit easier. on one side of the triangle at one point, we have passion. And if a relationship only has passion, it's a very simple kind of cake.
而亲密、激情和承诺都是三角形上的点。每个点代表一种爱情，连接这些点的线以及三角形的中心点也是如此。我知道这非常直观，但我认为给你举一些组合可能会帮助你更容易地理解这一点。在三角形的一侧，我们有激情。如果一段关系只有激情，那这就是一个非常简单的蛋糕。
It's infatuation. It's limerance. It's one side. It perhaps it's purely sexual in nature. It's driven by feeling, longing, and, you know, the thing that we want the most in the present, which is this other person. But it doesn't have intimacy. It doesn't have commitment.
它是痴恋。它是迷恋。它是一厢情愿。或许它本质上纯粹是性的。它由感觉、渴望以及，你知道的，我们在当下最想要的东西——另一个人——所驱动。但它没有亲密感。它没有承诺。
It's the simple cake. It's the passionate cake. If you only have commitment on the other. side of the triangle, you have empty love. Yes, you are loyal to one another, but romance and passion and intimacy have faded. You don't have that organic closeness. Think, you know, people who have stayed married for the kids, even when all else has faded, you know, there is still a kind of love there, but it's not the same as what they had. We also have purely intimacy. So intimacy is the other kind of part of the triangle, and that is like friendship. If you're just intimate,
这是一个简单的蛋糕。这是一个充满激情的蛋糕。如果在三角形的另一侧，你只有承诺，那么你得到的便是空洞的爱情。是的，你们对彼此忠诚，但浪漫、激情和亲密感已经消逝。你们没有那种有机结合的亲近感。想想看，为了孩子而维持婚姻的人，即使其他一切都已消逝，你知道，那里依然有一种爱，但它已经不再是他们曾经拥有的那样了。我们还有纯粹的亲密。所以亲密是三角形的另一部分，这就像是友情。如果你只是和某人亲密，
with someone and you just have closeness or familiarity, but you don't have romance or commitment, you guys are just friends. So three different kinds of love. Now for our combos, are you guys ready? If you have intimacy and passion, you have romantic love, you're dating, it's like the early months or the early maybe years. You don't know if you're going to go the distance, but you're having a really great time and you feel really close and comfortable and like in love with this person. If you have intimacy and commitment, you have companion love. And this. And this is, you're going to go to the can also be platonic. Think those like lifelong friends who like live with each other in their 60s. Think people who are older and they no longer have the same sexual feelings for each other,
并且你们只有亲近感或熟悉感，但没有浪漫或承诺，你们就只是朋友。所以有三种不同类型的爱情。现在来看看我们的组合，大家准备好了吗？如果你同时拥有亲密和激情，你就会拥有浪漫的爱，你们在约会，这就像是最初的几个月或最初的几年。你不知道你们是否能走到最后，但你们过得很开心，而且你感到非常亲密、舒适，并且感觉真的爱着这个人。如果你同时拥有亲密和承诺，你就会拥有伴侣之爱。并且这，你可以去，这也可能是柏拉图式的。想想那些到60岁还住在一起的终身朋友。想想那些年纪较大的人，他们对彼此不再有相同的性冲动，
but they're still all in on their relationship. Their love, these kinds of love is, they're just as real as any other kind of love. It just doesn't have that other ingredient to the relationship that Sternberg says creates consummate love. It doesn't mean it's any less meaningful. Fatuous love is when we have passion and commitment, it's incredibly rare because it doesn't have intimacy, which you think would be needed to connect those two things. Think like whirlwind courtships. People who get married after a few weeks, they have passion, sorry, and they have commitment, they don't have intimacy, there's no real bond there yet, but we would hope it would develop over time. Again, super rare, probably the most rare version or combination
但他们依然全身心地投入到这段关系中。他们的爱，这种爱和其他任何爱一样真实。它只是不具备斯滕伯格所说的创造完美之爱的关系的另一个要素。这并不意味着它不那么有意义。虚幻的爱是指我们同时拥有激情和承诺，这是极其罕见的，因为它缺乏亲密感，而你本会认为连接这两者需要亲密感。想想闪婚。那些几周后就结婚的人，他们有激情，抱歉，他们有承诺，但他们没有亲密感，还没有真正的纽带，但我们希望它会随着时间推移而发展。同样，极其罕见，可能是最罕见的版本或组合
And finally, the one we've been talking about this whole time, consummate love. This is described by this theory as the complete form of love representing the ideal romantic relationship that we are all striving for. We have intimacy, passion and commitment combined. This is the center of the triangle. Now, some things to dispel about consummate love. It's wonderful, it's beautiful, it's what we all strive for. it might not always last.
最后，也就是我们一直在谈论的那种，完美之爱。该理论将其描述为爱情的完整形式，代表了我们所有人都在为之奋斗的理想浪漫关系。我们结合了亲密、激情和承诺。这是三角形的中心。现在，关于完美之爱，有一些误区需要消除。它很棒，很美好，是我们所有人都为之奋斗的目标。但它可能不会永远持续下去。
This theory is not saying that once you have this thing, you have the perfect relationship. Having it for a certain period doesn't mean you're entitled to it forever. In fact, there's actually this urban myth going around that the reason Sternberg was so obsessed with theorizing about love was because he kept getting divorced and he wanted to know why the triangle kept collapsing in for him. But yes, it is a little bit of an urban myth. But, you know, based on his own personal experience, he does caution in his papers on the subject that maintaining consummate love may be harder than just achieving it. You know, he really does stress that these are just, all these components are important.
这个理论并不是说一旦你得到了这个东西，你就拥有了完美的关系。在一段时间内拥有它并不意味着你永远拥有它。事实上，甚至流传着这样一个都市传说，说斯滕伯格之所以如此痴迷于建立爱情理论，是因为他不断离婚，他想知道为什么三角形对他的生活来说总是会坍塌。但是的，这有点像个都市传说。但是，你知道，基于他自己的个人经验，他在有关该主题的论文中警告说，维持完美之爱可能比实现它更难。你知道，他确实强调了这些，所有这些组成部分都很重要。
Having intimacy, having passion, having commitment are important, but they are just the beginning. You have to translate those components of love into action. without expression, even the greatest of loves can die. And I think that's a really important message, not just for people in the 20s, but of any age, if you have a love that you want to last, you have to understand that love, especially the triangular theory of love, makes it so that this is also a verb. This is something that we act on. I think there's this idea that like when you meet the right person, you just know and it should
拥有亲密感、拥有激情、拥有承诺是很重要，但它们只是开始。你必须将这些爱情成分转化为行动。没有表达，再伟大的爱也会消亡。我认为这是一个非常重要的信息，不仅对二十多岁的人适用，对任何年龄段的人都适用。如果你想让一份爱持久，你必须明白爱，尤其是爱情三角理论，使得这也成为一个动词。这是我们付诸行动的事情。我想人们有一种观念，那就是当你遇到对的人时，你自然就会知道，而且它应该
feel easy. And this theory says that, yes, you may have everything you need to experience consummate love in the beginning, but it is not just the sum of its parts. You have to work for it. And the reason I really love this theory is because it doesn't think of love as stationary. It actually allows us to explain how love goes through many stages. We're going to take a short break, but when we return, I want to discuss what these stages actually are. 2%. That is the number of people who take the state. when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%,
感觉很简单。而这个理论则认为，是的，你可能在开始时拥有体验完美之爱所需的一切，但它不仅仅是各个部分的简单总和。你必须为之付出努力。我之所以非常喜欢这个理论，是因为它不认为爱情是静止的。它实际上让我们能够解释爱是如何经历许多阶段的。我们将稍作休息，但当我们回来时，我想讨论这些阶段究竟是什么。2%. 这就是当有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
我将剖析心理韧性、健身以及在我们奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations
我们在世界上惊慌失措的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即 T-W-O-P-e-r-s-e-n-t，可在 IHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将带来我十多年来在心理健康领域的个人经验以及与
with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。我们还在追逐，却不知道什么时候做得够多了。因为人们都在看记分牌。
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在人间做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两个不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正做一个好人。
Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd, found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed
加入我，科尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标进行真正的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。在2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会
revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see
揭露了她证词中明显的矛盾之处。这开始了长达数年的法庭之争，以证明真相。你对某人伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到
what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Maranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
他们的税都被花在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男子。格蕾丝，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·马拉吉尼。我的脑子炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by.
这是《爱之陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在 IHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。
Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck.
规则一，永远不要惹乡村女孩。玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们常说相信你的女朋友们。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《女朋友们》的这个新季节里……天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都约会过同一个多产的骗子。我感觉自己被卡车撞了。
I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
我想，这怎么会发生在我身上呢？警察似乎并不关心。所以他们自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼，不。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So like I said before, the triangular theory of love likes to explain how love goes through stages. It likes to kind of suggest that we begin with either passion or intimacy, then we gain the other, and then finally we have commitment. So at any given stage in a relationship, you can kind of place where someone is in the timeline of love by looking at where they sit on this triangle. If they're in the beginning stages, they might just have passion. if they're in the middle stage of their relationship, they might have passion and intimacy. If they're in the consummate stage, they have passion, intimacy and commitment.
在 IHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。所以就像我之前说的，爱情的三角理论旨在解释爱情是如何经历各个阶段的。它倾向于表明我们从激情或亲密感开始，然后获得另一种，最后我们有了承诺。因此，在关系的任何给定阶段，你可以通过查看他们在三角形上的位置，来确定某人处于爱情时间线上的哪个位置。如果他们在初始阶段，他们可能只有激情；如果他们在关系的中间阶段，他们可能有激情和亲密感。如果他们在完美阶段，他们拥有激情、亲密感和承诺。
But then as you maybe go further along on your relationship, you might lose the passion and just have commitment and intimacy. And then you might lose the intimacy and just have commitment. And then you might lose the commitment and have nothing. It also describes some of the relationships that happen in between, like situationships, like affairs. It describes friendships. It describes people who stay for the kids. It describes, you know, the people that you meet in those brief moments, maybe you're only for a couple of hours or for a week and you never see them again. You have this brilliant, beautiful moment.
但随着你的关系进一步发展，你可能会失去激情，只剩下承诺和亲密感。然后你可能会失去亲密感，只剩下承诺。然后你可能会失去承诺，一无所有。它还描述了介于两者之间的一些关系，比如“友情之上恋人未满”（situationship），比如外遇。它描述了友谊。它描述了为了孩子而留下来的人。它描述了，你知道的，你在那些短暂时刻遇到的人，也许只有几个小时或一周，然后你再也见不到他们。你有过这样精彩、美好的时刻。
Basically, I like that it doesn't show love as this static thing or as this, you know, singular kind of thing. I also like that for a theory and a rather dated one at that, it actually has a lot of real-world application and modern-day evidence. For example, a 2020 study looked at the application of this theory in 25 countries from all inhabited continents. It had over 11,000 respondents and it found that, yes, this theory actually does hold up under many different contexts and in many different cultures. This theory of love does represent many of the kinds of relationships. that people will experience and go through. Another reason I like this theory is because it can kind of act as a litmus test for whether the relationship you're in is fulfilling all that you want it to fulfill.
基本上，我喜欢它不把爱情表现为这种静态的东西，或者这种，你知道的，单一的东西。我也喜欢它作为一个理论，而且是一个相当过时的理论，实际上有很多现实世界的应用和现代的证据。例如，2020年的一项研究探讨了该理论在所有有人居住的大洲的25个国家中的应用。它有超过11,000名受访者，发现该理论在许多不同的语境和许多不同的文化中确实站得住脚。这个爱情理论确实代表了许多人们会经历和经历的关系。我喜欢这个理论的另一个原因是因为它可以充当试金石，检验你身处的关系是否满足了你想要的一切。
I think in our 20s we encounter a lot of half-baked relationships and we go back and forth on, is this person right? Is this relationship right or not? Should we stay? Should we go? And this is a great way of kind of analyzing our relationship and saying, okay but do we have intimacy? Do we have passion? Do we have commitment? If I seriously look at my relationship and it's missing one of these things, well, I actually don't have consummate love as much as I might feel like I have some kind of love. The thing is you probably do have some kind of love, but is it the kind of love that you expect and that you want that will fulfill all three of these needs for you? Now, something you may have noticed is that whilst the
我认为在二十多岁时，我们会遇到很多半生不熟的关系，我们在“这个人对吗？”、“这段关系是否正确？”、“我们应该留下来吗？”、“我们应该走吗？”之间来回摇摆。这是分析我们关系的一种绝妙方式，可以说，“好的，但我们有亲密感吗？我们有激情吗？我们有承诺吗？”如果我认真审视我的关系，发现它缺少其中一样东西，好吧，尽管我可能觉得某种程度上拥有某种爱，但我其实并没有完美之爱的关系。问题是，你可能确实拥有某种爱，但它是你所期望的那种爱吗？它是那种能满足你这所有三种需求的爱吗？现在，你可能已经注意到的一点是，尽管
triangular theory of love is definitely a good start. It is kind of missing some things. It's definitely got the foundations down pat. It's definitely stripped love to its very bare scientific stumps. But some researchers have remarked that it doesn't talk about culture. It doesn't really talk about the context in which a relationship is taking place. It treats the love between two people as if it's occurring in a vacuum. It doesn't include things like family expectations. It doesn't include things like values, religion, money, other circumstances that are keeping people apart. All these things do impact whether love lasts and where we sit on the triangle. I think favorable or unfavorable circumstances or the practicality of one's love should also be a
爱情的三角理论绝对是一个好的开始。它确实遗漏了一些东西。它绝对打下了基础。它绝对把爱情剥离到了最基础的科学根基上。但一些研究人员指出，它没有谈论文化。它没有真正谈论关系发生的情境。它对待两个人之间的爱，就像它发生在真空中一样。它不包括家庭期望等因素。它不包括价值观、宗教、金钱、使人们分离的其他情况等因素。所有这些事情确实会影响爱是否持久以及我们在三角形上的位置。我认为有利或不利的情况，或者爱的实际性，也应该成为
factor as to whether a consummate love will be achieved or will last. But again, I think this theory doesn't claim to have predictive powers over whether a love will last, you know, so we can't ask from it more than it wants to give. It kind of just gives the ingredients which will cause it to form. So again, maybe I'm asking a little bit too much from a scientific theory, but it's still something to think about. Another criticism is that it doesn't specify whether multiple multiple consummate loves can occur at the same time. You know, people in polyamorous relationships, for example, would claim that that can occur. But this is an old model and it doesn't kind of include or represent some of the newer forms of love that we are experiencing or seeing in the modern day,
是否能实现或维持完美之爱的因素。但同样，我认为这个理论并不声称对爱是否能持久具有预测能力，你知道的，所以我们不能对它要求超出它想给予的东西。它只是提供了导致其形成的成分。所以也许我对一个科学理论的要求有点过高了，但这仍然是值得思考的问题。另一个批评是，它没有说明是否可以同时发生多种完美之爱。例如，处于多边恋关系中的人会声称这可能会发生。但这是一种旧模型，它没有包括或代表我们在现代正在经历或看到的一些新型爱情，
especially since it was first created, founded in the 80s, when there was definitely a lot of love that wasn't socially acceptable or talked about, but was still valid. Finally, and this is the biggest issue I find with this theory, it doesn't cover whether one person can be in consummate love and another person just being in passionate love or fatuous love or empty love at the same time. it doesn't explain or provide an explanation as to whether two people in the same relationship can actually be at different spots on the triangle what kind of love is occurring then do both
特别是自从它在80年代首次创立以来，当时肯定有很多爱在社会上是不被接受或不被谈论的，但依然是合法的。最后，这也是我发现这个理论最大的问题，它没有涵盖同一个人是否可以同时处于完美之爱，而另一个人只是处于激情之爱、虚幻的爱或空洞的爱中。它没有解释或提供一个解释，说明同一段关系中的两个人是否真的可以处在三角形的不同位置，那此时发生的是什么样的一种爱呢？难道两个人
people have to be experiencing the same combination for the love to be that thing or could you have consummate love on one end fatuous love on the other and does that still count as a kind of love You know, this theory is very one-dimensional, right? It is literally a 2D triangle, look it up, you'll see what I'm talking about. But the feelings we feel towards someone at any given moment are multidirectional and they are 4D, 5D, 6D, and they are complex. You can have all three ingredients and still not be able to be together because you know it won't work or because distance keeps you apart or because there's another factor here that isn't being explained by this model. And, you know, what about people with relationship anxiety? Where do everyday doubts about our relationship fit into this?
必须体验相同的组合才能使爱成为那种东西，或者你可以在一端拥有完美之爱，在另一端拥有虚幻的爱，这仍然算作一种爱吗？你知道，这个理论是非常单维的，对吧？它字面上就是一个2D三角形，查一下你就会明白我在说什么。但我们在任何特定时刻对某人的感情是多方向的，它们是4D、5D、6D的，它们是复杂的。你可以拥有所有这三种成分，却仍然无法在一起，因为你知道它行不通，或者因为距离使你们分开，或者因为这里有另一个因素没有被这个模型所解释。而且，你知道，有关系焦虑的人怎么办？我们对关系的日常疑虑在哪里适合这个模型？
Does having doubts mean you can never be in consummate love? I don't think so. I think it's a very natural part of a relationship. And this is just another reminder that a theory is not a full, it's not going to provide the full picture. It's not going to explain everything. It's just a theory. This is where the quadruple theory of love comes in,
有疑虑是否意味着你永远不可能处于完美之爱中？我不这么认为。我认为这是一段关系中非常自然的一部分。这只是另一个提醒，一个理论不是全部，它不会提供全貌。它不会解释一切。它只是一个理论。这就是爱情四元理论登场的地方，
which has expanded on the triangular theory of love to kind of give it some more texture. The quadruple theory was first introduced in 2020, so a long time after the triangular theory. It's much newer and it proposes that love is built on attraction, connection slash resonance, trust and respect. This model, I think, describes how love develops over time much better. It also allows for more types of love to be analyzed since it has that fourth factor. I think it allows for parental love, love between friends, polyamorous love to fit into this model. And I like that it also includes resonance and trust rather than just commitment because you can be committed in a very basic way and still not trust the person you're with or have respect for them. So I think that this does go deeper into like the complex factors and the human emotion of it all.
它对爱情三角理论进行了扩展，为其赋予了更多质感。四元理论于2020年首次引入，因此远在三角理论之后。它要新得多，并提出爱情是建立在吸引力、连接/共鸣、信任和尊重之上的。我认为这个模型更好地描述了爱情随时间发展的过程。由于它具有第四个因素，它还允许分析更多类型的爱情。我认为它允许父母之爱、朋友之间的爱、多边恋之爱融入这个模型。我喜欢它还包括共鸣和信任，而不仅仅是承诺，因为你可以在非常基础的层面上做出承诺，但仍然不信任和你在一起的人或对他们缺乏尊重。所以我认为这确实更深入地探讨了复杂的因素和人类的情感。
It also describes the love cycle in a more, I think a less stagnant way. If you want to look up the quadruple theory of love, it actually has a model and a visual representation for the love cycle. It describes, which I think is a lot more comprehensive and beautiful. I think it's less of a black and white model as well, I love. But yes, this is a very new theory. It doesn't have as much evidence. But I do think a combination of the triangular and the quadruple theory would give us a much more complete version of what love looks like as humans. But I want to know. Do you think that with all this conversation about theories, love could ever actually ever be fully explained by
它还以一种我认为不那么停滞的方式描述了爱情循环。如果你想查阅爱情四元理论，它实际上有一个爱情循环的模型和视觉表现。它描述的内容，我认为更加全面和美丽。我认为它也是一个不那么黑白分明的模型，我喜欢。但是的，这是一个非常新的理论。它没有那么多的证据。但我确实认为，三角理论和四元理论的结合会给我们提供一个关于人类爱情样貌的更完整的版本。但我很想知道。你认为在所有这些关于理论的讨论中，爱情真的能被
a model or by a theory like these ones? Are researchers and psychologists just trying too hard to categorize something that can't be categorized? That's the big question. I keep coming back to at least. If we know every and any theory will be an oversimplification in some way or exclude some kind of love in another way, why do we keep attempting to create these models? And is love something that really needs to be studied or graft or can it only ever just be experienced? And that unique experience is as comprehensive as we may ever make of it. I don't know. I go back and forth. I really love looking into these theories, but sometimes I'm like, you're just never going to, it's never going to be the full picture. So why even try? But I guess they would say that trying is
像这些模型或理论完全解释清楚吗？研究人员和心理学家是否只是在过度努力地对无法分类的事物进行分类？这是一个大问题。至少我一直在回到这个问题。如果我们知道任何和所有理论在某种程度上都会过分简化，或者在另一种程度上排斥某种爱，为什么我们还要不断尝试创建这些模型呢？爱真的是需要研究或绘制图表的东西吗？还是它只能被体验？这种独特的体验正如我们可能做出的那样全面。我不知道。我来回摇摆。我真的很喜欢研究这些理论，但有时我想，你永远不会，它永远不会是全貌。那为什么还要尝试呢？但我猜他们会说，尝试就是
what gets us as close as we can be. I also know that when I was in my previous relationships, this model did help me understand what was missing. So it does really help in those ways and it does give words to a feeling. But I want to know what you think. Drop a comment below. Tell me how you feel. Tell me whether you think this is a good theory, a bad theory. And also give me some suggestions for some other theories you think I should cover.
让我们尽最大可能接近真相。我也知道在我之前的关系中，这个模型确实帮助我理解了缺少了什么。所以在这些方面它确实很有帮助，它确实给一种感觉赋予了词语。但我想知道你的想法。在下面发表评论。告诉我你的感受。告诉我你认为这是一个好理论还是坏理论。也给我一些关于你认为我应该涵盖的其他理论的建议。
I really want to do an episode, another Psychology Byrd's bonus episode on personality tests, whether they're a myth or not. I really want to talk about narcissism, sociopathy, all of those things, concepts that I think are talked about a lot, but which, you know, we may not have the depth of knowledge on them that we should have. So I would love to hear your ideas. And I want to thank you for listening to this smaller episode. Tell me what you think. Tell me if you like it. Make sure to share it with a friend.
我真的很想做一集节目，另一个关于人格测试的“心理学小点心”红利剧集，探讨它们是神话还是现实。我真的很想谈谈自恋、反社会人格，所有这些事情，我认为被讨论了很多的概念，但我们可能没有我们应该具备的关于它们的深度知识。所以我很想听听你们的想法。我要感谢你收听这期较短的节目。告诉我你的想法。告诉我你是否喜欢它。确保把它分享给朋友。
If you think they would enjoy it as well. And yeah, follow us along, wherever you are listening. So you get more content like this in your feed. give us a five-star review only if you feel called to do so. And I always forget to say this, but follow me on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. If you want to see some behind-the-scenes stuff, some like simplified breakdowns of these topics. If you want to be able to chat more with me about these episodes, I'd love to hear from you. Until next time, thanks for tuning in.
如果你认为他们也会喜欢的话。是的，关注我们，无论你在哪里收听。这样你的信息流里就会有更多这样的内容。给我们一个五星好评，前提是你觉得有必要这么做。我总是忘记说这个，但是在 Instagram 上关注我，账号是 That Psychology Podcast。如果你想看一些幕后花絮，一些这些主题的简化解析。如果你想能够和我更多地聊天关于这些节目，我很想听到你的声音。下次见，谢谢收听。
Stay safe. Be kind. Be gentle with yourself. We will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is all. an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness,
注意安全。保持善良。对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再次交谈。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理韧性、
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
健身以及在我们奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all day the same prolific con artist.
收听《2%》。即 T-W-O-%。可在 IHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都约会过同一个多产的骗子时。
They take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
她们自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们常说，相信你的女朋友们。听听女朋友们的话。相信我，宝贝。在 IHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。
On the Look Back at a podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam Jay And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it
在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时期的
with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it
与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家们一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。那真是个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。收听《Look Back at It》
on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
在 IHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯。这个空间聚焦于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都根本不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一位懂行的持证专业人士进行交流。
How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。这并不意味着你需要。在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。这是一个 I-Heart 播客。真人保证。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。